I've got people in the chat here asking
about this this kid Aiden and a few
other you know the younger like twitch
streamers like you've had a lot of
interactions with these guys since you
you know since you blew up on the
internet it seems like that's the main
demo like I think my demographic's a
little bit older than you probably
because I'm like 15 years older than you
but like a lot of these kids with twitch
streams and YouTube channels would like
fairly large audiences you know you've
connected with
um what are they missing in life like
what is it that they're doing
everything everything you know the
modern the new generation Richard is
[ __ ] bro it's it's incredible let me
ask you a question
before the internet did you ever know
what 20 year old self-made millionaire
no
no these kids aren't supposed to have
this much money they're dumb asses
they're children before the internet the
idea that you could become a self-made
millionaire at 21 was absolutely
impossible no one would even take you
seriously in a business meeting it
couldn't be done but now it can be done
so you're giving all these kids money
and clout and attention what what do you
think they're doing with it dumb [ __ ]
gambling drugs buying girls presents
hanging around with hoes
stupid [ __ ] they're literally lost their
souls are lost their hearts and minds
are lost they don't have any experience
what did we say earlier that money
amplifies we're amplifying children what
do you think they're going to do with it
children [ __ ] they're [ __ ] clowns all
of them every single person I've ever
spoken to on Twitch without exception is
a [ __ ] clown none of them are serious
people they don't take themselves
seriously they don't take their income
seriously they don't they're not even
smart enough to sit and go I'm making
all this money at 21. let me really
buckle down for a few years and set
myself up for life no they're too busy
[ __ ] oops I'm late oops I was drunk
yesterday cancel stream oops oops they
are children
total dummies all of them have you seen
any of them adopt any of the advice or
any of the teachings that you've
provided
I have faith in Aiden he's the only one
I have some Faith left in so I'm trying
hard with Aiden to show him that if I
was his age with his kind of money I
would be so far ahead than I already am
like I couldn't even afford to [ __ ]
eat the guy should at least be in shape
get personal trainer and get a dietitian
you have all the money in the world why
are you out of shape it's ridiculous I'm
trying to instill something in him
because if I can make him transform his
life because of his popularity it will
genuinely Inspire millions of children
so I am trying and I am trying with a
philanthropic goal with a good heart I
have some faith in Aiden but the rest of
them are completely lost they're they're
popular so you might have to correct me
here because I don't watch their [ __ ]
but they're popular because they twitch
stream themselves playing like fortnite
or they're just [ __ ] talking each other
online is that
is that where they got their popularity
from yeah I don't completely understand
it either there's a degree of luck in
who blows up and who doesn't and um
obviously sometimes there's some luck
involved or I don't know sometimes some
big event happens to one of them and he
kind of blows up but what's they end up
being the background noise for children
so the kids who sit on the internet all
day sit in the internet all day with
these streams in the background and kind
of semi watch them with their semi
barely semi-con uh cognitive brains just
ingesting the garbage while they play
video games and talk [ __ ] barely
sentient individuals on both sides of
the screen it's a very remarkable
insight into how [ __ ] the world is
it's truly everyone on Twitch is a loser
everyone on Twitch is an Uber and
there's full grown men on there as well
and I've spoken to them and they're
losers all of them yeah there was some
40 or 50 year old guy who was the oldest
fortnite player that you had a back and
forth dial the guy with the purple hair
I think he was in the airport when you
were talking to him that guy like yeah
like this is
just lost individuals and it's not it's
not me hating on the platform because I
mean it's a video hosting platform right
it's just hating on the idea of people
sitting and consuming for 10 hours a day
some other person talking [ __ ] and
wasting time it's all a big it's all
pretty detrimental to Western Society
I'm going to try my very best with Aiden
he's the one I believe in most and I
hope I can get something out of it